everybody can Coleman back with you
again for another edition of backseat
driver it's July that means it's
America's birthday March I can't think
of a better car to take our guests out
in than this 72 Chevelle Haley hey
thanks for doing this hey you're welcome
all right now take a look at the car
what do you think it's awesome it's a
muscle car in the backseat today is
American icon Lee Greenwood Lee has 16
number-one hits including the classic
god bless the USA he's a friend of
Dave's a true storyteller and a blast to
hang out with so Lee I got to ask you
what was your first car 1955 Chevrolet
four-door it was two-tone green and let
me tell you I got it right as I left
high school my grandparents bought it
for me as I left for Reno Nevada and
there was a guy obviously drunk but he
had this like box in his hand and he
said hey I'll paint something on your
car if you want and I'm like okay cool
it what do you want I said flying tiger
five bucks
Wow why flying tiger I don't know I
would love to know how an LA kid becomes
a country music icon you know my father
joined the Navy in World War two right
after the bombing of Pearl Harbor and my
mother was really upset with that she
felt desertion so she divorced him so in
order to have my mother have a life she
shipped us to the farm in Sacramento
with my grandparents we had a spinet
piano in our farmhouse and it was the it
was instrument my mother played in the
evening I was allowed to sit and play
the piano in the dark
my grandmother's smart enough I don't
want you looking at the keys I want you
listening to the keys so I developed a
lot of ear training by playing in the
dark so I played piano for a couple
years and at the same time I developed a
baseball career at a music career Wow
I was scouted by the Dodgers and as I
was leaving high school I just thought
I'm just too small
ain't gonna happen for me and music was
already taking over my life I left
Farina right out of high school and
didn't even go to my graduation so I'm
excited about this children's book I got
it right here this is cool stuff I know
you're proud of it talk about it you
know I because of the success of the
song god bless the USA which I wrote in
1983 on the back of my bus I just didn't
think that looking back people really
needed the kind of reinforcement like we
had with our children Kim and I read to
our two young boys who are now 20 and 16
every single night we never really read
them anything about the United States of
America and how what it means to be a
patriot how important it is to honor the
red white and blue and have what it
stands for and that is the freedom our
country it is so important to teach that
lesson early I want to know what's going
through your head in that moment you're
in the back of the bus and you start
pinning this song we were writing so
much music this wasn't even designated
as a single this was an album filler and
so I had the cassette in my pocket so I
asked my driver I said word is Irving
Azoff live Irving Azoff was the
president of Universal right that
controlled all Universal Music and the
Nashville label and the driver says in
between Barbra Streisand and Neil
Diamond in Hollywood
take me there it's Halloween night so I
Drive our limo right up to Irving Azoff
house he's standing in the doorway with
the three children dressed as bumblebees
and I walk over to him standing in the
doorway and I pull out the cassette tape
and the other what do you think I said
trick-or-treat what was his response he
said who are you
I give him the cassette take some sticks
and a cassette player plays it he said
are you scheduled for the album I said
ready for release
he said bring it to me when you come to
Los Angeles and so then I ended up
flying out to Los Angeles with the whole
album and so at the end of it he asked
me what do you think the single should
be and I say well what do you think and
that was the moment the defining moment
where he said I think it should be god
bless USA three times on three different
charts in America's history and there
were many events that led to that of
course the Gulf War Katrina the attack
on America and so forth and so on so
we've lived with it long enough to know
that it was a good thing that we do and
the emotion is still very very real for
you you know why is that because I'm a
simple farm boy from Sacramento
California and I'm an icon and you can't
believe you're there love that I love
that you appreciate it so much when you
allow yourself to think about that this
song is just below the national anthem
and god bless america
it's there it is such a signature which
I would never raise it above those I
know you wouldn't but it truly is there
what does that mean to you I have this
opportunity you know to not only
entertain but make people stand up and
be proud of their country now this is a
little awkward after we're talking about
the emotion of the song but would it
have killed you to set lakes of Michigan
have killed you hold it out said Detroit
anyone I'm kidding of course you're in
the car with me for backseat drivers so
I gotta ask will you sing the song for
me I'm proud to be an American hold on
I'm sorry that's me now this is awkward
oh I don't I don't want it to be in the
car I've got a perfect spot for it
perfect venue you still cool with it or
we're poor I love Nashville I look all
right where are we going
yep
where
today
whoo attaboy lead
that was fun